bonjour jean marc en france le président
du conseil scientifique a déclaré ce
week-end que l'épidémie était sous
contrôle que les français avaient envie
de vivre et c'est vrai que beaucoup
s'impatiente les restaurateurs par
exemple à les compagnies aériennes les
écoles des études viennent de montrer
que l'économie pouvait repartir plus
vite dans certains pays que dans
d'autres de quoi est-ce que cela dépend
écoutez c'est important parce que ces
agences de notation elles permettent
d'évaluer la capacité des gouvernements
et des états à rebondir et ses agences
de nature donnent des notes finalement
différents états et c'est notre
permettent de savoir si on pourra prêter
de l'argent à ces pays ou ne pas
emprunter alors elle donne des dates du
triple a pour seul qui se pour les pays
qui se comporte très bien jusqu'à
baisser pour ceux qui se comportent les
moins bien la grosse surprise vous le
disiez la chine pourrait semble bien
s'en sortir
l'europe est très mal partie sauf
peut-être le royaume uni alors c'est
effectivement la chine dit s'en sort le
mieux
alors que la pandémie est partie de chez
elle finalement la chine
eden va s'en sortir positivement avec +0
7% c'est le seul pays à éviter le recul
de son activité sur l'année
essentiellement grâce à l'ampleur de son
marché intérieur puisque ses débouchés
extérieurs ont été largement hypothéqué
la majorité des commerces de la chine
continentale sont restés ouverts sauf
dans la province du yunnan
alors que des magasins occidentaux
heureux ont été fermés corée du sud
corée du sud vous le voyez 1,2 pour cent
la banque centrale de corée du sud
prévoit un pipe 2 0 et de là pour ça et
donc plus optimistes la corée du sud a
évité l'effondrement en activant des
mesures de protection et puis vous avez
japon -5 la russie - 5 %
les etats unis 5 g de 6% les états unis
limitent les dégâts
ils ont une capacité de rebond le brésil
- 6 % parce que le brésil continue de
travailler en dépit des grosses
difficultés sanitaires et des dégâts en
vies humaines alors que la zone euro
elle est très mal va être très mal parce
que 8 2% 2 décroissance c'est
considérable pour la zone euro
l'allemagne fait -6 6% la france va
faire moins 9%
d'ailleurs
mais les plus pessimistes que ça parce
que bruno le maire a annoncé la semaine
dernière - 11 % l'italie 9 ennemis
l'espagne 9 6 la belgique 19 voyez que
l'ensemble de la zone euro
bah c'est pas faux c'est pas formidable
mais alors à quoi sont dues ces
différents saint jean marc écouter ça
dépend évidemment de l'état sanitaire
vous savez bien voir l'état des
équipements hospitaliers
ça dépend des plans de relance les plans
soutien mais ça dépend aussi de la
situation antérieure à la crise beaucoup
de pays qui sont dans une situation
compliquée étaient des situations qui
n'avait pas fait de réformes
structurelles auparavant en europe c'est
très clair c'est l'europe du sud qui a
des difficultés parce qu'elle avait des
difficultés auparavant l'italie
l'espagne la france
alors si je mets de côté globalement sur
la planète la chine qui est très
particulière il ya trois pays qui s'en
sortent bien l'allemagne à la situation
la plus favorable
c'est le fruit de sa résilience j'allais
dire quasi historique sa capacité
d'organisation résidence quasi coupure
est plus surprenant deuxième fois des
états unis qui font preuve d'une
capacité à se redresser
relativement vide vous avez vu des
chiffres du chômage la semaine dernière
il y à des facteurs là encore qui sont
des facteurs démographiques culturel les
populations et c'est très cynique ce que
visent les économistes les plus touchées
sont très clairement parmi les plus
défavorisés aux états unis socialement
ils ne sont pas inséré forcément dans le
système économique
on les a un peu laissé tomber et puis la
plus grosse surprise
elle est même assez incroyable elle
provient de la grande bretagne le
royaume uni dont on n'a pas beaucoup de
chiffres actuellement qui a pourtant été
très abîmée par des réactions politiques
un peu incohérente de bris jonnson
pourrait au final se hisser dans le
tiercé de tête mondial pour sa capacité
à rebondir pourquoi et bien tout
simplement parce que la grande bretagne
parce que boris johnson va sans doute
profiter de la crise pour pousser très
loin la libéralisation de son économie
en le voyant
il est de plus en plus dur dans les
négociations avec le break site ce qui
agace d'ailleurs beaucoup les européens
moins d'impôts moins de charges
on va faire peut-être du dumping le
projet c'est un peu de copier naba le
modèle de singapour singapour c'est une
sorte de paradis fiscal
on ne sait pas ici des européens
laisseront faire parce que ça va être
tout l'objet de la verve de la
négociation qui est en lui et qui est en
cours actuellement avec le royaume merci
beaucoup jean marc sylvestre je rappelle
que vous êtes un journaliste
éditorialiste économique